why are you laughing
because my dream is dead
[Laughter]
oh i do have
one question
hold on oh my god
sorry andy are you getting sick it's flu
season again and i cannot get sick stock
up on kleenex don't touch your face
don't touch anything
people are dropping like flies we
already have to quarantine larry
leslie i don't feel good can i just work
from home the tent is your home now
larry we already forwarded your mail
take it away guys
this is such a great day for
[Music]
peace
oh man this is amazing man the stupid
eagletonians are totally getting pwned
by these bees
we'll send this straight to tash
[Music]
don't worry babe i'll protect you i got
stung once i'm immune
go ahead and sting me bees it does
nothing
ben he's winning how is he winning
everything he's saying is nonsense and
he's fooling them
you're doing fine i need to go back on
the attack no no no no no
see okay when you attacked you kind of
came off like a bully and he looks
sympathetic so
you know you did a really good job of
easing off leslie this is fun isn't it
yeah recount there's a recount
oh come on it's over just concede
newport won by 21 votes that's well
within the margin for a recount
please don't do this i really want to
get out of here how about this
why don't i make you guys a deal okay
there's no deal in the world that we
would ever possibly
give you joe biden's home phone number
now hang on that's interesting
you're not thinking clearly mr
commissioner the recount has to start
immediately it's the law
and i'm not leaving until you make the
call he's ride miss barkley
it'll start right away keep your phones
on terrence
i just want to go home
school is out in two weeks what am i
going to do with my kids all day
keep them in my house where i live hey
man you want to go for a jog
just sort of kick out the cobwebs get
some endorphins going
oh no thanks chris kind of tearing this
claymation video a new one right now
you know ben i really think you need to
take a step back here
i think getting some perspective would
be good what are you talking about
i've known you a long time and right now
you
need help with my clay mage
with your life you are wildly
insanely depressed depressed
i'm the furthest thing from depressed i
mean look what i've accomplished
do you see him do you think a depressed
person could make this
no i'm sorry but the ben wyatt that i
know
i just don't think he'd be happy he's
sitting here faffing around
i'm not faffing around i've sucked
myself into my hobbies
here i'll show you my claymation project
okay now i've been working pretty hard
on this and
i think it's really good so just hang on
to your hat okay
okay here it goes
oh great
did you pause it no i hang on
oh my god that's the whole thing
that's three weeks of work you're going
to be okay no no no no i'm not
you see in my head i thought that was
really really cool
i i emailed leslie two days ago and i
compared it to avatar
chris and how can it not be longer
you